botar todos temos já foi explicar três
vezes mais
não sei se isto acontecer com vocês
nos últimos tempos sempre tem que falar
com o estorno empresa portuguesa com
alguns gestores dessas empresas
portuguesas parece que não tem muito
tempo para prestar atenção aquilo que eu
digo parece que tem agenda muito
preenchida a resposta é não temos muito
tempo mas isso está preocupando e
preocupa por uma razão é porque não
estão a prestar atenção devida que o que
se passa à sua volta e unir este
provavelmente a partir do susto da vida
deus
e aí é tarde demais para falar com quem
quer que seja o desvio encontrado aqui
hoje é exatamente esse
como é que nós podemos fazer com que os
gestores das empresas portuguesas em vez
de apanhar um susto de sua vida ganha a
oportunidade da sua vida
mas para fazer isso é preciso
contextualizar e é isso que eu gostaria
de fazer
nós neste momento estamos a traçar uma
alteração profunda do nosso programa
competitivo e que eu quero as regras de
gestão que nós aprendemos na
universidade há 11 anos estão a ficar
cada vez mais obsoleta é que eu quero os
fatores críticos de sucesso da nossa
indústria estão a ser cada vez menos
críticos processo e que quer garantir
nossa empresa pouco tem garantido hoje
em dia qualquer causa em causa é simples
nós temos neste momento a atravessar uma
profunda revolução tecnológica
nós chamamos de digitalização a
digitalização traz consigo novas formas
de comunicar novas formas de
socialização novas formas de trabalhar e
à medida que se vão incorporar no nosso
dia a dia é que o que acontece é que vão
quebrando barreiras geográficas
barreiras linguísticas barreiras negócio
e isso tem uma conseqüência muito clara
é que muitos dos gestores que não têm
tempo para nos ouvir tem agenda muito
preenchida não estão muito preparados
presta novo contexto competitivo e que o
que acontece é que muitas empresas que
nós temos com empresas referência deixou
de ser desaparecem da face da terra
muito rapidamente se apresentar os dois
exemplos é o primeiro bloco basta vida
enquanto estavam no lugar de vídeos
desaparecer da face da terra teve a
oportunidade curiosamente comprar o
netflix achava
era demasiado cara não percebeu que uma
onda digital queria pôr em causa o seu
negócio
nós temos outro acolá que coloca
assistiu até o último minuto culpa era
digna da fotografia analógica esquece o
que vinha a vaga da fotografia digital
não se preparou para isso e quando
acordou quando apanhou o susto de sua
vida já era resgatado para registro na
realidade nós vamos entrar no novo
modelo econômico estudo econômico a
chamada de câmera digital onde chama de
economia pós capitalista outros chamam
lhe ainda claudicam nome uma economia em
que a palavra de ordem e cooperação
entre partidos para desenvolver novas
oportunidades de negócio e é sobre isso
que estamos aqui falar mas curiosamente
esta cloud gaming traz uma coisa
adicional consiga para a qual nós não
estamos muito preparados é que nosso
principal competidor não se encontra no
nosso setor da atividade enquanto os
setores de atividades paralelas e cada
um para o nosso como nova contexto o
novo dna de pensar
ali a oportunidade de negócio duff
também dois exemplos a melhor empresa de
transporte personalizados e que gera
bastante polêmica
não tem um único meio de transporte seu
o a maior empresa de aluguer de
apartamentos turísticos também não tem
um único apartamento seu estamos a falar
num modelo de negócio radicalmente
diferente vai ser um problema pode ser
uma oportunidade um grande amigo meu do
porto costuma dizer é competição faz
vencedores e vencidos
é uma grande verdade é que os gestores
que estávamos a falar porque tem muito
tempo para nos ouvir
tipicamente estão focados nesse evento
de hoje todos nós queremos ser
vencedores naquilo que fazemos
a realidade é que este jogo da
competição e ser vencedor de matar a
concorrência de gerir o estado school
para que se transforme sempre vantagem
para mim pode matar o negócio mas ainda
os dois portugueses ainda não perceberam
que portugal e as suas empresas não tem
nem tempo nem dimensão para jogar este
jogo é meramente competitivo fundo a
crise econômica que nós atravessamos ao
longo dos últimos anos
o vôo express em inúmeros postos de
trabalho
os milhares
postos de trabalho que necessitamos
agora para revitalizar a nossa economia
não vem da evolução tradicional e
gradual dos nossos negócios da inovação
disruptiva mudar os meus negócios de
olhar para a realidade das contas
digital na forma radicalmente diferente
da realidade é preciso quebrar as regras
é sobre nós temos aqui falar a
competição é destinada à cooperação para
ensinar novas regras e para criar este 9
contest
nós temos aqui um tema que algumas
empresas já perceberam que apesar de
serem e servem os competidores também
podem ser sujeitos processuais
há dois meses atrás toda a indústria de
tecnologias foi um murro no estômago
microsoft apple e mitificada as 13 anos
vem dizer pro tema da nulidade
nós vamos ser pessoais sabem quantas
vezes mais ou vão ganhar com esta
parceria diz e os especialistas quantas
vezes mais a ganhar com esta parceria do
que se fizesse isoladamente
algumas estão três vezes mais
efetivamente especialistas dizem que os
por fax desta parceria
vou acelerar o seu desenvolvimento do
negócio em três vezes mais do que se
fizesse isoladamente por exemplo também
muito feliz ao ouvir bmw e mercedes
juntaram esforços para comprar a divisão
a da nokia relacionada com mapas e
software de gps para introduzir nas suas
viaturas
sabe aquela que é a dimensão da poupança
destas empresas três vezes mais sendo
ver a lógica é exatamente isso
nós competimos comprar o som das nossas
necessidades complementares três vezes
mais do potencial do valor em cima da
mesa neste caso temos aqui um tema é que
nós podemos fazer isso que eles fizeram
é preciso novo mais sete novos
resultados mas como nós sabemos a coisa
mais difícil de usar a cabeça das
pessoas
na realidade enquanto nós temos mudamos
ou não enquanto nós moramos este tempo a
decidir o que fazer
além da oportunidade neste novo contexto
global iria ditar algumas empresas
portuguesas já perceberam
algumas empresas portuguesas até muito
próximo aqui já são líderes nas áreas e
efetuaram temos um exemplo prosis equipe
póvoa do lanhoso que o líder europeu na
distribuição de produtos suplementar os
suplementos alimentares ou mais
mediáticos quiserem da gandra farfetch
que um dos principais players no portal
móvel
imagine estas empresas em vez de
trabalharem sozinhos serem potenciadas
pelas indústrias que estão na sua base
industrial alimentar e indústria da moda
que em portugal também tem bastante na
mídia
imaginem que nós conseguimos criar um
ecossistema com o objetivo não numa
lógica dos grandes contra os pequenos
não lógica dos rápidos contra os lentos
mas lógico que aquilo que tenha base de
clientes tabela e tem a capacidade
financeira do oxigênio financeiro
permitem criar e alimentar as pequenas
empresas têm o dna diferente e que
precisam dos recursos deste primas para
poder crescer e denisar se no mercado
português apenas temos pensar de forma
diferente temos que pensar no mercado
global e esse desafio
três vezes mais é isso que eu chamo uma
dinâmica que nós continue competindo
poderemos desenvolver os princípios já
temos é preciso mudar a mentalidade
nessa idade há três regras fundamentais
que todos nós enquanto gestores de
empresas temos que seguir para que isso
seja uma realidade
o primeiro é muito simples temos que
acabar com a lógica do copianço que o
chame o síndrome do café da esquina
explicar rapidamente o manoel tem um
café na nossa rua café da esquina
toda a gente fala que a fé do manel a
certa altura passa alguns vizinhos
dirigir amanhã passa muito bem se quiser
também pode fazer o café e essa altura
parece um café na rua
os clientes que não ficam vão se
dividindo dias depois passar alguém ele
já até que os dois não se saiba em dois
cafés na mesma rua aqui a tendência
esquerda também consiga alguma parte
daquela partida que eu vou fazer a mesma
coisa e faz a mesma coisa
não não percebendo que cada vez que
alguém entra neste setor está a destruir
valor para todos os anteriores mas pra
eu também tenho que pensar de forma
diferente não é copiada que faz esse é o
tom que ele que duraram poucos é que
pessoas com os turcos nas principais
cidades é que o pessoal com o sol segue
os passos de veículos
toda a gente hoje em dia tem um génio
português o melhor disco melhor daquilo
que faz cursinho passado
temos de pensar de forma diferente de
ensinar valores a segunda regra mais
simples ainda temos que ser rápido
estamos a atuar no mercado global em que
tudo que nós fazemos pensar rápido atuar
rápido olhar rápido recuperar rápido em
algumas situações sair daqui é o setor
rápido
muitas vezes nós não temos totalmente as
competências para o engrossar o coro tem
uma regra muito simples escolher bem os
nossos principais conversas sejam
parceiras se complementem nas suas
abordagens podem competir podem comprar
acima de tudo para sair tenho mesma
atitude que ela seja alguém que está há
um ano com vocês para negociar um
contrato de colaboração não é o parceiro
certo trecho no contexto pensei que eu
costumo dizer livro falou org até lá vai
não perco muito tempo neste novo
contexto isto dizer o que minha mensagem
base nós para além de competirmos
podemos comprar
nós temos um potencial em cima da mesa
como alguns exemplos mostrar três vezes
mais do que fazendo exatamente isso não
depende apenas de nós depende do nosso
ecossistema que o desafio de forma muito
simples exercício de começarmos esse
movimento três vezes mais aqui
já quando eu acabar a minha intervenção
eo meu desafio é isso
quando eu acabar a minha intervenção
vocês pegam em três cartões de visita e
temos três cartões de visita pelas
pessoas com a vossa volta quem sabe
nessa nossa volta não existe o parceiro
três vezes mais
e daqui online estarmos aqui e se livrar
um crescimento da nossa empresa três
vezes superior aquilo que vocês podiam
fazer o isolamento das do desafio mas
também uma coisa é que o nome do porto
costuma dizer conquistam vagas dos
vencidos não fica porque eu costumo
dizer é com pressão fazer ofensiva
ele estava de mensagem obrigado